We have a voicemail number which is two one
nine two David p this is a really interesting
question.
There is not been a lot of discussion about
Bernie Sanders being Jewish as a, uh, as one
of the leading 2020 Democratic primary candidates.
I got a voicemail from a viewer that has a
question about this and it's actually very
interesting on a couple of different levels.
Take a listen to this
Bernie supporter.
I'm also Jewish and I am afraid that if he
would like to that uh, and something goes
wrong as for example, recession, it'll be
blamed on Jews and uh, you know, people are,
am I being too paranoid?
I know you're Jewish.
Do you think about that possibility?
Uh, interested in your opinion?
I'm thinking of switching my support.
Elizabeth Warren have, it'll be blamed on
women.
No, just kidding.
Um, uh, but uh, no, I'm, I'm serious.
People get crazy and I don't want to exacerbate
lightened anti Semitism so if we could have
the same thing, the same Paula, similar policies
with the, with the Elizabeth Warren.
I think I prefer that.
What do you think?
Yeah.
Here's what you have to understand.
Whether or not Bernie is precedent stuff is
already all getting blamed on Jews.
I mean, listen, you go back to the Iraq war
of 2003 and those who have the tendency to
want to blame Jews say the real culprits of
the 2003 Iraq war, our juice.
Because you know, Paul Wolfowitz worked for
George W. Bush and Donald Rumsfeld I think
is Jewish, worked for George W. Bush.
And so the Jews are to blame for the 2003
Iraq war.
You go to Latin nine 11 conspiracy theories,
uh, Jews, Israel slash the Massaad for people
who have these tendencies are a day or they
are blaming the Jews.
So yes, you are right.
If Bernie is president and things don't go
well, it will be blamed on the Jews.
But the Jews are blamed anyway.
And what you have to understand is that w
with Bernie being Jewish, sure Bernie winning
the nomination, if it were to happen, will
be attributed to too conspiratorial crafty
Jews working together.
This is to be expected.
It's not a good reason not to support Bernie
if that is who most aligns with your political
views.
The Jews have been blamed for everything under
the sun for thousands of years by the conspiracists.
And that's going to continue whether Bernie
Sanders is the president or not.
Those who seed you, if all you have is a hammer,
everything looks like a nail I think is the
way the phrase goes.
And if you consider Jews as people I've interviewed
sometimes consider if you consider the Jews
to be the problematic group, the Harbinger's
of negative consequences, uh, et Cetera, uh,
than any problem that you identify with society,
you are going to blame on them no matter who
is president of the United States.
So yes, you're right.
Bernie Sanders will certainly, uh, receive
criticism on the basis of antisemitism and
blaming Jews for everything.
But that exists anyway.
And I would just vote for whoever most aligns
with your policy ideas.
We've got a great bonus show today.
We are going to talk about, we've not talked
much about the central park five and its connection
to Donald Trump on the regular show.
We are going to talk about that on the bonus
show today.
We will also talk about Domino's pizza, starting
to deliver pizzas via autonomous robot this
year, and I will still not order Domino's
pizza, but that's not the main focus of the
story.
And then we will also talk about the situation
involving conservative Kyle [inaudible] and
Harvard resending.
It's admission offered to him.
I actually met Kyle at Politiken in October
of 2018 and we will talk about that on the
bonus show as well.
Two ways to get instant and permanent access
to the bonus show.
Become a member at www.
Got Join patflynn.com or become a patron at
patrion.com/david Packard,